have you ever woken up and dreaded the
idea of work or school or simply life
you convince yourself that what you're
doing is for some kind of purpose some
dream and yet you're barely able or
willing to weather the path to get there
that's the case is that really your
dream
losing friends
[Music]
for this cleanliness food water
all of life's most wonderful blessings
for work
[Music]
Japan's population has been on a steady
decline since the 1980s resulting in a
constant labor market shortage
on top of this there were excessive
layoffs and restructuring to adjust for
economic collapse in the 90s resulting
in what we now see as intense pressure
and demand that's put on the few workers
who actually are present in the
workplace who are essentially taking on
an immensely greater volume of work an
amount of work that often comes at the
cost of their well-being
let's just think of it this way they've
got the same amount of work to do as
anyone else but less people to do it
with so everyone is doing more
just to add to it all whether or not
this is a result of this situation or if
it just arose independently Japanese
culture generally values long hours as a
display of hard work though this is not
always the case this is in no way a
complete and comprehensive description
of all companies across Japan but in
many company environments leaving on
time means you're leaving early and
early means you aren't loyal enough to
the company we see this intense pressure
in Psalm 100 where workers compare and
brag about how long they worked for
unpaid overtime together
whether it's because they've convinced
themselves that this work is their
purpose and their dream like Akira or
because their manager demands extra
hours for them or if they see extra
hours as some kind of competition and
admire as if sleep deprivation is a
desired trait
feeling of being trapped
that there's no way out of this societal
pressures workplace pressures the
pressures from yourself
that's how Akira feels in Psalm 100
bucket list of the dead and that's what
makes this show about a very fictional
zombie apocalypse very very real
that the one thing to gleam from the end
of the world as we know it and the onset
of the Apocalypse is that hey I don't
have to go to work tomorrow
it's an absolutely insane idea and yet
after looking at the conditions in Japan
I can't help but resonate with it
though zom100's depiction of oculus
company is an embellishment there still
lies a truthful Foundation beneath it
all one that becomes painfully clear
when you realize that akita's company is
based off of Studio olm where many of
the animators of Psalm 100 used to work
now we know that working conditions for
animators in Japan is far from ideal
after everything we've seen with mapa
and all the other controversies it's one
of the industries in Japan that's gained
the most notoriety in recent years
and so whether or not this Easter eggs
on 100 is a playful dig at the former
company or a genuine expression of the
company's conditions for their past
workers we don't know
but considering what we see I I wouldn't
be surprised if a lot of this was rooted
in real complaints
seeing the sheer amount of anime being
produced every season it's safe to say
as mentioned earlier that the volume of
work far outweighs the amount of people
that exist to work on it
but overwork isn't exclusive to Japan in
fact Japan isn't even the worst of it
paling in comparison to a number of
Asians specifically Southeast Asian
countries
even in the U.S we are no exception to
having people overworked and not paid
enough for what they're doing
and that's why it's actually so fun to
see akita's story pan out in the first
episode and in what follows because just
about all of us can understand the
sentiment even if yes we don't have it
as bad as him
having no work means real freedom
that's something that resonates in so
many people's heads in our souls
akita's story also evolves rather
quickly as it grows from him just having
an Indulgence in beer free time and
motorcycles and turns into a realization
of what he's really been missing while
he's been working himself
his passions his dreams
Psalm 100 shows that work often builds
you into someone you think you want to
be but it's only when you stop
when you finally tell yourself that it's
enough that you realize that that was
never your dream
is just
work
losing this burden gives Akira the
chance to be the person he imagined as a
kid
a superhero
a free spirit leaping from the rooftops
riding across Tokyo in his sweet
motorcycle
it's one of the few takes in fiction
where a zombie apocalypse the end of the
world is shown as such an amazing thing
which is awesome
I mean yeah it's it's horrifying to see
these zombies and watch them eat people
but with the way they've made the blood
to be this super bright pop of color
makes it feel like this is almost a
fantasy
a dream in a way
it's akita's Imagination Running Wild as
he's now in a world where he can finally
do anything he wants
even if it means it's filled with
zombies
for many of us Watchers this story about
a person in a zombie apocalypse is
somehow a breath of fresh air it's a
place we ironically want to be
transported to
that's not something you see very often
it's because it depicts such a brutally
real and relatable attitude towards work
and the workplace in just the first
episode that we sympathize and start to
dream with Akita of what we could do in
a place with no work no limits this
isn't the zombie apocalypse or anything
like that if it were in any other
setting at the end of the world
this story wouldn't change at all no one
cares about that Psalm 100 is just a
story about freedom
and who doesn't want freedom even if it
comes at the Peril of being chewed up
and torn to shreds by flesh-eating husks
of former friends and lovers I know I do
as long as it means I don't have to go
to work tomorrow
zom 100 is airing I think every week now
on Netflix so do give it a watch if you
haven't already I do recommend it it's a
fun really fun show and pretty
informative if this video has told you
anything
I've made some videos previously on what
it's like to work in Japan as a mangaka
and as a Japanese animator so if any of
the topics or ideas in the first episode
of zom 100 interest you in any way I'd
recommend watching those just to
understand a bit more and fully really
get a grasp of the conditions in Japan
across the world quite frankly but in
this industry specifically of anime and
manga it's really important to
understand just exactly what's going on
behind the scenes so thank you guys for
watching as always
this has been the anime culture corner I
hope you enjoyed the video don't forget
to like And subscribe for future
in-depth show manga and character
analyzes